eu espero que vocês estejam bem na casa
de vocês eu tô muito feliz de tá aqui
dentro desse momento tão especial muito
as coletividades incríveis e eu sou da
bahia de salvador quero mandar um beijo
muito especial para jaque jaqueline
entendeu estou aqui com ser rápido de
canela também pode e a música para mim é
objeto de transformação de mudança e de
cura e essa música vocês podem fechar o
olho e se sente olhando agora nesse
momento para bahia tá bom ai ai ai ai ai
a mão entrega ai ai ai ai ai ai ai palma
da mão e
é o bem maior de sonhador como a
entender a nota de coração de pão e
porta não inspiração inspiração para
entender e explicar o caminho da razão
eu tô falar o cheiro gostoso eu sou
feliz do meu anjo é que mãe eu tô de
mares ia eu lembro mata bahia com água
de coco e canção do meu violão abre as
asas sobre nós
e abra as asas meu amor tá
e a palma da mão comigo vem ai aia ai ai
aia ai ai aia o bem maior de sonhador a
nota que o coração porta não inspiração
você já aspiração verdade deus para
entender que explicar o caminho da vão é
um elo sorte para nós maravilhoso você
tem um cheiro gostoso e
o que é hoje mainha tá demais zinho meio
da mata bahia pneu violão velho apesar
para vocês sobre meu amor vai vir para
casa de vocês e
e respira na palma da mão para a gente
saudável gostoso ai ai ai ai ai ai
entrega trabalhar ai ai a cada my eyes
e não fala nada não é
e aí
bom então o nome dessa música na palma
da mão é a primeira canção de trabalho
que eu fiz logo depois do the voice em
2013 a gente olha só essa canção e 2014
e lança seu primeiro disco e desse novo
trabalho meu tá tudo muito relacionado
ao cotidiano da minha vida do meu dia a
dia e até que eu tenho visto e passada
no meu dia a dia e tem uma canção que
faz parte desse meu dia a dia que eu
acho que tem muito a ver com esse nosso
momento eu sei que quem tá trabalhando
de casa quem tá produzir de casa sabe da
importância de a gente está em casa da
gente está ligado ao outro a gente tá
com quem a gente ama isolado a nossa
casa mas às vezes está isolado na nossa
casa da gente ter tempo para outras
coisas de observar outras coisas tem
gente que tá enrolado em casa não está
produzindo porque faz parte desse
momento também e precisa ter aquela
outra pessoa mais perto a gente sempre
quer ficar mais mais tempo com ela essa
música é para quem sofre com a falta de
tempo do outro e mesmo assim
é tentada fica mais
como é que para mim não tá tão fácil
sacar que tão distante de você coisa não
vai melhorar que você ficar sem tempo
até para dar uma longe às vezes penso
que é verdade outras acho que é caô
tirar a gente da sua agenda aí me fala
onde eu me encaixo e vira amiga menina
aí no carro eu te acho de acho que tirar
da sua agenda aí me fala que limpar se
vira você é uma menina aí eu acho hoje
populares quanto que é
e esquecer um pouco a vida adulta hoje
eu quero ser sua profissão
e fica mais ficar mágica marcelo compra
nesse vender tá gente nunca mais o mundo
tá andando aqui ficando para trás fica
mais eu quero como você vem deixa ficar
mar fica mar o mundo tá andando desenho
explicando para entrar
oi gente ficando para traz aqui para mim
não tá tão fácil sacar então distante de
você a coisa não vai melhorar é que você
se tá sem tempo até para dar uma valor
às vezes penso que é verdade outras acho
que a cá o tem que dar sozinha daí me
fala onde eu te embaixo se vira uma
menina aí tá onde diacho tirar da sua
agenda aí me fala onde as mina pira uma
menina acho hoje eu posso fala para tu
cancelar a reunião
se esqueça um pouco a vida adulta hoje
eu quero ser essa profissão fica mais
tomate camarão castelo compra nesse bem
você sabe ainda mais ficar mais não
também a gente ficando para entrar eu
tava contando não tá andando a gente
digitando para pegando para trabalhar
[Música]
hoje eu quero seu bem
o e encerrar quero agradecer mais uma
vez a todo mundo ficar aqui com a gente
ao vivo nessa corrente de pensamento
positivo uma corrente de clarêncio e
doura muitíssimo esclarecedora muito
obrigado a todos muito obrigado a quem
tá escutando muito obrigado altar dex
pelo convite espero que seja o primeiro
de muita um prazer tá aqui e eu tinha me
programado para fazer uma canção só que
essa tarde com todos esses rebuliço seu
tanto de coisa que as pessoas têm
demandado tenho visto muitas músicas
falando sobre o momento que eu vi sua
muitas canções falando sobre como está
sendo esse momento de isolamento e eu
recuperei uma melodia antiga com os
parceiros que eu fiz lado dele tem um
monte de uma canção que estava guardada
no baú e eu mudei a letra um pouquinho e
eu falei para ele vou mandar a letra da
música e vou fazer uma música para
quando a gente acabar com tudo isso a
gente poder se misturar a se embolar
esse esse de ré descobrir né com fé em
deus é isso que a gente quer quando tudo
isso
e descubra mesmo com todo esse momento e
eu espero que tudo isso passe da forma
menos dramática possível sem querer
romantizar todo tudo que a gente tá
passando com com esse com essa pandemia
mas deixar uma mensagem para que quando
tudo isso acabar a gente vai se
encontrar se abraçar se olhar se sentir
sentir a energia do outro e com certeza
a gente vai estar transformado então
quebrando todo protocolo vou fazer uma
canção inédita para vocês vão me
desculpando deixar letra aqui perto de
mim porque eu acabei de fazer essa letra
então vamos lá como é que eu bora bora
bora bora bora que hora de embalar agora
fica assim ó bora bora bora bora mas não
é a hora de se embalar
é a minha verdade com a sua meta bad
para minha vontade feliz família segredo
é um pano de medos caminho pra gente
[Música]
seguir palavras tomadas despesa aqui na
sorriso ainda viu minha linda
em segundos do agora chamar demora
semente pro nosso jardim ii
e bora bora bora não é hora de falar
falar bora bora bora bora que não é hora
de colar o
o simba lá muito obrigado a todos vocês
tenha uma boa noite obrigado até que
tamo junto